wir sind unterwegs nach
Rheda-Wiedenbrück zum Stammwerk von
Tönnies Deutschlands größtem
Fleischproduzenten seit einem Jahr gilt
in der Fleischindustrie das
werkvertragsverbot will ich Lohnarbeiter
aus Osteuropa müssen seitdem im
Schlachthof angestellt sein wir sind mit
die Metro verabredet zehn Jahre hat er
bei Tönnies im Kühlhaus gearbeitet
zuerst für einen rumänischen
Subunternehmer dann im Zuge des Gesetzes
wurde auch die Metro Tönnies Mitarbeiter
doch seine Freude Werte nicht lang nach
einer OP darf er nicht mehr voll
arbeiten für Tönnies wurde er damit
unbrauchbar glaubt die Metro was
passiert mit so Kranken Mitarbeitern das
sehen sie ja man kriegt die Kündigung
stundenweise gäbe es nichts für mich
haben die von Türen jetzt gesagt ich
könnte ja wiederkommen wenn ich gesund
bin
Kündigung weil er krank ist dabei sei
seine Erkrankung voll seiner jahrelang
schweren Arbeit im Kühlhaus von Tönnies
ist die Metro überzeugt
es ist nämlich tatsächlich eine Schande
dass Menschen aus Mittel und Osteuropa
aus Bulgarien und Rumänien in dieser
reichen Gesellschaft ausgebeutet werden
und das werden wir beenden an dieser
Stelle
Frühsommer 2020 die Politik greift ein
als Corona in deutschen Schlachthöfen
ausbricht tagsüber zersägen Osteuropäer
Schweine im Schlachthof nachts wurden
sie in Sammelunterkünfte gepfercht von
Subunternehmern angeworben verschlissen
und schließlich fallen gelassen es
Corona machte das zum Skandal
auch Deutschlands mächtigster Schlachter
kündigte Reformen an wir werden diese
Branchen verändern
das steht fest
an die 25.000 Schweine schlachte Tönnies
täglich vielleicht als Massenware dafür
braucht es viele billige Arbeitskräfte
6000 seiner ehemaligen
Billiglohnarbeiter hat Tönnies
inzwischen im Zuge des Gesetzes
übernommen aber was passiert wenn diese
Mitarbeiter wie im Fall von dimitro
krank werden nachdem sie jahrelang für
Tönnies geschuftet haben
wir fragen nach beim
Unternehmenssprecher versucht man kranke
Mitarbeiter loszuwerden ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass es da ist weil
derjenige krank ist sondern das
vielleicht andere Gründe gibt dass
manchmal ja vielleicht auch gerade
einfach in einigen Abteilungen der gar
nicht der Bedarf da ist aber das kann
ich jetzt nicht genau bewerten also bei
uns im Film äußern sich Menschen dazu
dass sie genau das erlebt haben müsste
ich mir im Einzelfall angucken nehmen
sie sich kenne ich kenne das jetzt nicht
das höre ich jetzt zum ersten Mal das
müsste ich dann bewerten wenn ich mir
angeschaut habe
Tönnies hat die Metro gekündigt ohne
Gründe zu nennen dimitro ist überzeugt
seine Erkrankung sei der wahre Grund
auch für die Unterkünfte von Arbeitern
schreibt das neue Gesetz jetzt
Mindeststandards vor Bilder von
Massenunterkünften wie diese soll es
nicht mehr geben tatsächlich hat Tönnies
im vergangenen Jahr etliche Unterkünfte
in Werkswohnungen umgewandelt die Anzahl
der Bewohner reduziert einige sind
trotzdem unzufrieden und wollen mit uns
über Ihre Wohnverhältnisse reden ein
Berater von fairem Mobilität begleitet
uns
weit kommen wir nicht
eine Mitarbeiterin von Tönnies
Immobilien will uns den Zutritt
verweigern verlangt eine Genehmigung wir
gehen rein ohne Kamera
oben treffen wir sieben Männer und
Frauen in einer Dreizimmerwohnung 200
Euro zahlen sie fürs Bett die Miete wird
vom Lohn abgezogen erzählen sie dann
wird doch dieses Gespräch unterbrochen
plötzlich steht der Hausmeister der
Hausmeister im Flur und
alle werden plötzlich ganz kleinen die
wohnst nur sieben Sorten Zahlen 1400
Euro Mieter der billig ist es nicht
Clemens Tönnies wollte die ganze Branche
verändern den großen Durchbruch sagt der
Berater gebe es bislang noch nicht noch
nicht nein das hat er noch nicht
geschafft also ich glaube eine Branche
umzukrempeln da da ist wirklich ein
bisschen da wäre jetzt noch ein bisschen
noch mehr dran und Deutschlands
Fleischindustrie ist auch mehr als nur
Tönnies viele kleinere Fleisch und
wurstproduzenten müssen möglichst billig
produzieren ohne osteuropäische
Arbeitskräfte geht das nicht die meisten
wohnen nicht in Werkswohnungen sondern
kommen privatunter und dafür gibt es
keine neuen Regeln wir sind in
Harsewinkel an diesem Morgen Wissen
Katalin und Nikolai zwei Arbeiter der
Fleischindustrie nicht wohin von ihren
Mitbewohnern wurden sie vor die Tür
gesetzt Nicolai haben sie die
abgebrochen und alles wegen eines Anrufs
beim Amt der ist ja deswegen verprügelt
worden
weil ich beim Amt angerufen und gefragt
habe ob ich noch positiv bin
weil das Amt nach katalins anruft 7
ihrer Mitbewohner unter Quarantäne setzt
seien sie auch aus der Unterkunft
geprügelt worden erzählen sie und dass
die alten Strukturen mit ehemaligen
Subunternehmern noch immer gut
funktionieren
im deutschen Schlachthof wo ich arbeite
gibt es rumänische Vorarbeiter und die
Arbeiten mit rumänischen Vermietern Hand
in Hand
als Garantie dann nehmen Sie uns die
Pässe weg
hier in diesem Einfamilienhaus haben
Nikolai und Katalin gewohnt bevor sie
verprügelt wurden wir klingeln bei der
rumänischen Vermieterin
hallo guten Tag sind Sie Marie Nizza
ich wollte Ihnen gerne ein paar Fragen
stellen
die Rumänen marinita vermietet das
Dachgeschoss gleich an mehrere
rumänische Landsleute bestätigt die
33-Jährige sie hole sie aus Rumänien und
vermittle sie an Reinigungsfirmen oder
die lokale Fleischwirtschaft
und wo arbeitet er zerlegen was ist
Arbeit mit Messer Ende 2021 allerdings
sollen an dieser Adresse zeitgleich 22
Personen gemeldet gewesen sein und das
sind alles Freunde aus Rumänien die
jetzt in Deutschland arbeiten wir sind
alles wie ein kleiner Familie eine geht
klar wo ich versuchen andere haben aber
wie kommt es dazu dass hier 22 Leute
gemeldet sind
22 Leute nein nein nicht 25 aber wieso
sind so viele gemeldet hier nein weil
ich habe nicht habe gemeldet
ihr bleiben nur die Vermietung erzählt
die Rumänen mit dem werkvertragsverbot
gegen ihre Personalvermittlung Pleite
die Kreditraten fürs Haus aber laufen
weiter sie ist finanzieren das Haus mit
den mit der oberen Etage ja weil die
sind da ich habe Haus gekauft aber eine
Rate gerade nicht war heilen kann keine
300.000 € zu bezahlen ein Haus aber was
sagen sie zu dem Vorwurf dass er Leute
quasi
von Ihnen oder Ihrem Mann oder von
Freunden verprügelt worden sein sollen
nur weil sie das Gesundheitsamt
informiert haben von der
corona-infektion die Leute hat zu mir
gesagt die sind Quarantäne ist positiv
ist das okay muss sie ja zum Kreis guter
so anrufen und dann
Quarantäne musst sie verprügeln keine
Leute die bei ihnen oh mein Gott nein
niemals
in Deutschland gibt es tausende private
Unterkünfte für osteuropäische
Arbeitskräfte in diesem Fall kündigte
die Stadt Harsewinkel eine Überprüfung
wegen Überbelegung an
zurück in Rheda-Wiedenbrück bei Tönnies
frontal wurde eine Liste zugespielt
darin bemängeln Aufsichtsbehörden für
die Jahre 2020 und 21 seitenweise
schwere Verstöße beim Arbeitsschutz es
geht um versperrte Fluchtwege die
Nichteinhaltung von Mindestabstand
abgeklebte und herausgerissene
Sicherheitsschalter von schweren und
tödlichen Verletzungen ist da die Rede
die Tönnies für seine Arbeiter billigend
in Kauf nehmen würde weil der Schutz
gegen das hineingreifen entsägeblatt
absichtlich festgebunden war und an
anderer Stelle die Gefahr des
hineingezogen werdens während des
laufenden Betriebs besteht wir zeigen
die Liste einem Experten
[Musik]
also das ist ja mehr als
menschenverachtend dass man billigend in
Kauf nimmt dass Menschen da abstürzen
können und in die offenen
zerschneidungsmechanismen und Trichter
und Schneckenfallen und tödlich tödlich
zermalen werden also ich
also die Behörde müsste da sofort diesen
Arbeitsplatz stilllegen
zuständig ist die Bezirksregierung
Detmold dort heißt es man kontrolliere
Tönnies inzwischen fast täglich Zitat
die Bezirksregierung hat 15.500 Euro an
Bußgeld im Jahr 2021 bei den Betrieben
der Tönnies Holding vollstreckt warum
muss es erst die Behörde feststellen und
warum kommt das Unternehmen nicht selber
drauf dass dann Sicherheitsschalter
abgeklebt ist dass der
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen manipuliert
werden dass da Menschenleben in Gefahr
ist dadurch dass man einfach sagt wir
wollen hier schneller arbeiten den
ganzen sicherheitskram lassen wir mal
weg das hält uns nur beim Arbeiten ab es
ist natürlich individuelle Fälle in
denen das passiert und das macht der
Mitarbeiter in dem Moment dann nicht
böswillig sondern weil er glaubt dass er
damit selbst seine Arbeit so ein
bisschen erleichtern kann und das
tolerieren wir natürlich nicht wenn er
sich oder andere in Gefahr bringt wenn
Sie es nicht mehr Sicherheitsschalter
von Arbeitern selbst überbrückt und
abgeklebt dimitru erzählt uns etwas
anderes nein die kleben wir nicht ab das
machen die Vorarbeiter damit die Arbeit
am Band nicht unterbrochen wird es heißt
immer schnell schnell mein Kollege hat
sich die Hand gequetscht der musste bis
Schichtende weiterarbeiten und jetzt hat
er kein Gefühl mehr in der Hand wie
lange brauchen sie denn
um also in die falsche Richtung zu
korrigieren
also ich kann jetzt nicht sagen wir
brauchen nur so und so viele Jahre das
hängt natürlich auch immer von Land zu
Land unterschiedlich ab was man da auch
für Gegebenheiten und dabei stelle ich
gebe mal ein Vergleich wenn wir jetzt
den Kohleausstieg anschauen ja da wird
gesagt das dauert da geben wir euch mal
25 Jahre Zeit bei uns waren es jetzt 14
Tage wir reden nach einem Jahr und
Clemens hat sich vor anderthalb Jahren
hingestellt er will die Branche
verändern jetzt fragt sich natürlich
wieder wie lange braucht der Mann dafür
bei uns wird noch einem Jahr drauf
geguckt und wird gesagt naja ein
bisschen was gemacht aber viele Dinge
sind noch nicht natürlich das wir sind
dran es gibt auch noch viel zu tun
Nikolai und Katalin die beiden
fleischarbeiter landen in einer
Notunterkunft enttäuscht vom Leben in
Deutschland und von Behörden die sie
nicht schützen können